on the subject of gay Australians
gentlemen here what is uh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
may I inquire
Javier oh my God you are the least gay
man here
you just impregnated the entire front
row
it's like it's not even my period happy
yeah
you get pregnant on your period Chris
that's how it works
so uh how are you what um what what
country did you were you born in uh
Mexico Mexico [__] yeah which bit uh
Mexico Mexico City holy [__] that's you
were shocked
you were just there but now you're here
so you could [__] hear instead
[Applause]
pretty cool
pretty cool I mean it's not you know out
of all it's one of the biggest cities in
the world I think it's like the third
biggest city in the world used to be the
biggest but then you've got overtaken by
China which you know
um
you know I think Mexicans started covert
to kill off Chinese people so they could
get their status back with the biggest
city that's just me it's just little
opinion I spread on Reddit
so
Javier who is a human embodiment of a
Hawaiian cocktail
it's just like you know because the
shirt screams pineapple and the hair
screams pineapple
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I would assume drug Smuggler but what do
you what do you do
you're a an influencer of course where
you've influenced these ladies vaginas
to become very modest
oh
that's pretty cool what um how many may
I ask how many followers you have
10 million 10 10 million on Tick Tock
that's pretty [__]
that's pretty impressive I imagine I
don't know I'm not on it because I'm
over 30 and not a sexual predator
you're allowed on it because you're
making the content everyone else get the
[__] up
you know under 21 you shouldn't be on
there so I mean when you were growing up
Javier I mean what type what type of
content do you make I do a movie and TV
show reviews movie and TV show reviews a
lot of Spanish shows specifically uh a
little bit of everything but I do it in
Spanish in Spanish cool yeah I mean
that's the third biggest language in the
world isn't it yeah English is still
bigger
[Music]
but the thing is I feel like having it
maybe maybe you were similar to me and
that you were like ah the English Market
is flooded I'll do it in Spanish I feel
that in the same way that in the UK I'm
terribly unfunny and then I came over
here
our audiences will just laugh at
anything a British man says he's so
smart
so you do the movie reviews when you
were a little Javier because you're what
in your mid-20s
when you were little implementing wasn't
a thing or Tick Tock wasn't anything
what did you want to be when you were
little
uh I wanted to do something with movies
something with movies
you review them now now you review them
you cut out the middle man you were just
like
it's hard to make a movie isn't it
I could just sit there
go three stars and get [__] rich
[Laughter]
I'm sick what's your what's your
favorite movie of the last year
um
I really loved everything every while at
once everything ever all at once made by
the Daniels which uh I I saw it on a
plane which I don't think is really the
way men are experience it you saw on a
plane too holy [__]
it's great I mean I feel like we have a
spiritual connection it's like a
triangle between you and me
may I inquiries to your name madam
Jada lovely to meet you Jada and Jada
are you from New York
San Francisco you said that with a
disdain for this city which I do not
feel that anyone from San Francisco is
allowed to have
um like oh New York but have you looked
at your city Happy Looks in it
um
I like it it's pretty good
Jada what do you do
HR oh how many people have you fired
this month
why are you gesturing to him
I mean with shorts that short you must
have violated
[Applause]
all right now what um what what industry
are you in
fintech oh Financial technology for
anyone who doesn't speak San Francisco
you're there like she works with
dolphins
[Laughter]
fintech HR Jada from San Francisco when
you were a little girl Jade what do you
want to be
a princess oh lovely stuff lovely stuff
which uh which princess because I mean
back when you were a little girl
Princess Tiana didn't exist there wasn't
a black area so who are you
that wasn't now
there's Role Models but back then
Pocahontas was the closest that is so
[Applause]
excuse me
but a young black girl in San Francisco
had to be like without she's brownish I
guess
[__] John Smith could get it
oh yeah
just ignore the fact that technically
she was 14 in the movie
um it was a different time wasn't it
um
what was you have you seen Pocahontas
have you oh yeah yeah what was your
review of Pocahontas
unrealistic
you know when John Smith and Pocahontas
lie down on that blanket she would have
caught smallpox wouldn't she would
how do you say paint with all the colors
of the wind in Spanish how do you say
paint with all the colors of the wind in
Spanish
the main song from Pocahontas
didn't review it you watched it when
you're a child
you watched it a long time ago Okay cool
so we've got we've got Jada who works in
fintech in HR I wanted to be a princess
in San Francisco we have Harrier who's
from Mexico City who is an influencer on
Tick Tock technology who loves loves
review movies and did want to be in
movies but then decided why bother with
effort
and he looks like a pina colada
well that's good um so Gina do me a
favor let's uh let's let's hit this
because growing up I I wanted to be a
rapper that was my dream and we'll find
out whether I pursued it we'll find out
when I achieved it but this is a little
freestyle for Jada and Javier both names
with that little silent one but no and
this is going to be pretty [__]
exciting so for you guys and for the
rest of you lesser let's do this cool
a picture of a beautiful man hairier
than anyone you've seen front row area
his name is Javier where's he coming
from so pretty follicular ditty from
Mexico City
people over there South of the Border
and they seeing light where you're so
famous whoa follow us lots it's like
CeCe we see you on Tick Tock what 10
million for a silly man there I'm not
being mean I really do care you sat in
the movie like I mean I'll judge this
[__] what I see on the screen Robert De
Niro all the [__] Al Pacino all the [__]
I wanna watch something that's like a
party you prefer Margot Robbie in the
Barbie maybe
you were spinning it back Christopher
Nolan like Translating that in Spanish
what does he even say does he translate
the bhagavadi to that way I have become
death destroyer of girls worlds wait
you're the guy destroyer of girls
because so beautiful that's a little
mind slip you wanted to make the movies
but you're like I'm [__] with camera
work directing and acting and so I'll
just do there sit backing and pass in my
judgment like a film reviewer that's so
brilliant people see right through you
and how long are your reviews surely
it's like 15 seconds or maybe 22 people
go thumbs up or thumbs down you were
looking everywhere for a princess who
was brown and you found it near it
plus he's got the long hair and is black
and that matches so you thought yeah I
throw my ball in her court and walk
around this forest with my little
friendly raccoon I hope some European
settlers come soon ah take the ball The
Colors Of The Wind the other one you
could have thrown yourself in was Mulan
because she's at least not white that's
literally the two ones that you had in
the fight Walt Disney we can all say
this he hated people of color he's so
racist he was saying no oh the
princesses have to be white he would
turn in his grave he would get such a
fright if he saw the little mermaid what
did you think about that one with the
girl swimming there in the drink did you
like it he's like yeah one thumb up not
two but that's okay got fun disgust
you're in San Francisco the worst city
by far working in fintech in HR such a
great job really admiring basically
you're like yes I do the firing you sir
you're fired yes it's your fault cause
you committed the Grievous sexual
assault your shorts were very skimpy up
there we can see your thighs with your
lovely body hair walking in the office
look at my limbs no the only Tech we
deal in here is fins like dolphins or
sharks or whales Free Willy that would
be a Free Willy cause the Short's so
silly well there we go a flame wrapping
to persuade you so give it up the
heavier and give it up for Jada
oh